happy April Fool's Day now while it is
the day to be habitually trolled on the
internet this is a friday show which
means i have a sacred duty to tell you
about the things that actually happened
in gaming this week so i'm gonna do that
now since you aren't getting any
hilarious yet mildly annoying april
fools jokes in this episode let me tell
you about the free games you can get
with PlayStation Plus this month Sony
concerned that there will be six games
on offer this month including shut see
me and a virus named Tom for PlayStation
Vita I am alive and savage moon for ps3
in addition to dead star and zombie for
ps4 the latter of which you probably
remember better a zombie you when it was
previously a wii u exclusive if xbox is
more your thing Microsoft have been busy
announcing a bunch more backward
compatible 360 titles for Xbox one just
this past week microsoft revealed that
left 4 dead 2 halo wars soul calibur 2
and the king of fighters 98 are all now
backward compatible on the Xbox one left
4 dead 2 was one of the most voted upon
additions to the lineup on the Xbox
feedback site the most popular titles
though which includes Skyrim red dead
redemption and call of duty black ops 2
aren't available as backward compatible
just yet a whole lot of Final Fantasy 15
News flooded in this week and while i
could probably feel a whole episode with
it i'm gonna roll through it quickly the
highly-anticipated uncovered event
really didn't disappoint as square enix
announced an anime prequel series called
brotherhood ACG feature film called king
slave a mobile game called justice
monsters 5 a final fantasy 15 demo
called platinum demo which is available
now both a deluxe and collectors edition
for Final Fantasy 15 and a release date
for the game which is just 6 months away
on sep 10 to 30 of this year you can
check out all the details as well as all
the brand new trailers on gamespot the
next free content update for halo 5
guardians is out later this month but
343 have already dropped the details
new match the expansion will feature two
new maps girma [ __ ] dark star and tyrant
skirmish a dark star will be the
smallest war zone map and it features
some really tough promethean bosses who
will hijack UNSC vehicles and call in
reinforcements tyrant is a small scale
symmetrical map that is designed for
capture the flag and assault mode the
map lends itself to snipers as it
features strong sight lines between
bases if you want to read our in-depth
look at the maps complete with tips from
the dance on how best to take them on
you can check out our story on site and
finally a number of reports have been
coming in suggesting that Sony is
working on a more powerful ps4 console
called the PlayStation 4 K kotaku
Eurogamer and The Wall Street Journal
have come forward claiming they have
inside sources who can confirm Sony is
working on a ps4 which can better handle
higher end gaming experiences like
virtual reality the console will
reportedly have enhanced graphics
processing power while sharing the same
software catalog as the regular ps4 and
will be unveiled before the release of
PlayStation VR in october according to
The Wall Street Journal Sony's plan is
to quote capture gamers willing to pay
for a richer gaming environment
including a high-end virtual reality
experience so near yet to come forward
with an official announcement about the
console let me know down in that comment
section what mattered to you this week
and to be sure to tell me if you're
going to be getting into any of the Xbox
backwards compatible all playstation
plus games this weekend this week on
site I tell you about some of gaming's
best exploits ever on the gist we cover
up on some crucial beginner tips for
dark souls 3 and the fallout 4 show
takes a look at deployables turrets that
is everything I have to tell you about
this week as always be sure to have
yourself a lovely weekend and I will see
you again on Monday